The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GANG CHEN: OK.
Hope you had all a good weekend.
It was very lovely.
We had a lot of fun
during the weekend.
So recall what we were
talking the last lecture.
We discussed the
Maxwell equations.
Electric field-- this is a,
say, very magnetic field,
general electric field.
Current generate magnetic
field, and what Maxwell added
is the displacement field that,
say, the time derivative also
generate magnetic field.
So this setup for equations
from the Maxwell equation.
And one comment I
thought I forgot to make
is this is actually called
macroscopic Maxwell equation.
And you can write
atomic Maxwell equation
that does not involve
the displacement,
because displacement,
recall, is the polarization
due to external field plus
external field together.
It's the response of the
atoms to the external field.
And similarly,
magnetic induction
also includes magnetic moment
and, say, magnetic field.
So the atomic Maxwell
equation, actually, you
can go to write without
those, say, D and B.
But you have to sum
up overall atoms.
And you do not use the
concept dielectric constant.
And this is, in fact, the
area that we're currently
trying to work on to bridge--
to build a bridge between
the heat conduction
and electromagnetic wave.
Because we're doing an
experiment when two surface is
really, really close--
like 1 nanometer close--
originally we're
using the macroscopic
of Maxwell equation.
But in this regime,
we're no longer--
we're questioning whether
that's valid or not.
So by coming back from this
set of macroscopic Maxwell
equations, we can find
a plane wave solution
for the wave propagating
in a homogeneous media.
A homogeneous media means
I have the permeability
and permitivity--
permitivity and permeability
independent of space.
So it's a function of
frequency, but it's
independent of free space.
And in this case,
the wave vector,
when we substitute
back into the equation,
we find the wave vector
is related to frequency.
That's a dispersion relation
through the permitivity
and permeability, which
when we will normalize
to vacuum values, we have the
relative dielectric constant
and the relative
magnetic permeability.
And so this is the square.
So if I take the magnitude
of the wave vector--
right, this is vector--
magnitude of wave vector,
I can write this equation
in terms of omega.
And omega equals CK.
That's what you're familiar
with for free space.
Right?
See the wavelength
times frequency
equals speed of light.
That's what it gives.
And this N is the refractive
index, the optical constant
of the material.
And different material have
different optical constant.
But it's not a constant.
And it's very
frequency-dependent.
So it's a misnomer.
So if you take the
derivative of N--
normally we take only
the positive root.
So most of the case,
don't worry about it.
It's a positive root.
Refractive index equals square
root dielectric constant
and relative magnetic
permeability.
And but in optical frequency
range, this is one usually.
So it's really just the square
root of dielectric constant.
And because this one could
be including imaginary part,
so when you take
a rood, generally
your optical constant
have a real part
and an imaginary part.
And the imaginary
part is associated,
particularly epsilon r, the
imaginary part associated
with the loss.
And correspondingly,
this kappa, which
we call extinction
coefficient, is
also associated with loss,
the damping of the wave
when it propagates
through the medium.
And we said, if you
check, basically these
are all characteristics you
can derive from the equation,
this plane wave solution.
And if you plug in plane wave
solution, you find that this E.
You can also use
that to find the H.
The E is perpendicular
to H. So that's--
the two fields are
perpendicular to each other.
And it's perpendicular to
the direction of propagation.
And that's why electromagnetic
wave is a transverse way.
It's perpendicular to the
direction of propagation.
And also, normally it's
a right-handed wave
because it's E cross H
gives you the K direction.
And that's when you
take the square root
as a positive and
negative square root
is just a recent invention.
The theory was there, but
let's say it was really--
it's a [INAUDIBLE]
field that is based
on designing
artificial structures
so that when both epsilon
the mil are negative,
you should take a
negative square root.
We commented that at
end of last lecture.
So this where we were.
It's basically giving
you the vector equations.
And if you recall, before this
we're looking at the electron.
It's not-- it's a scalar wave.
We're looking at the electron
reflection as a potential step.
So we give a reflectance and
transmittance at the interface.
And where we're going
is doing the same thing.
I have electromagnetic wave
comes towards the interface.
What's the corresponding
reflectance?
What corresponding
transmittance?
And similarly, after that
we go to acoustic wave.
And acoustic wave is a more
complicated [INAUDIBLE] wave
because it has
three polarization--
longitudinal, which is
the same as the K vector,
vibration direction,
and two transverse.
So that is even
more complicated.
But we're going to at least
give you some idea of those.
Oh, different waves
actually behave,
from wave perspective,
actually, very similarly
in terms of the behavior.
So let's continue.
And what we want first
is a further look
at the wave propagation
in homogeneous medium.
And if you use the
Maxwell equation,
this is what you can prove.
And I'm not going
to write the mass
because it's a very involving.
I mean write vector.
Let me just point out--
so when you use Maxwell
equation, what you can,
do you can multiply
H to this equation.
What do you see,
B is mu H, right?
So that's 1/2 mu H square.
That's like the magnetic
field energy, stored energy.
And if you multiply
this by E, and what
you have here is a epsilon,
say, D is epsilon E, right?
So you get 1/2 half
epsilon E squared.
That's the electrical
field energy stored.
And when you add
them in together,
the left-hand side
will give you the rate
of change of energy
stored in the system,
if you take it any
system and you apply it.
And the right-hand
should be the flux
that's going across
the system boundaries.
So that's the interpretation
if you do your math operation.
And what you find
out is then that flux
of energy going across
the system boundary
gives you the energy flux
of electromagnetic wave.
And this is the Poynting vector.
Poynting vector
is E cross H. So E
cross H is the energy
propagation direction.
OK?
And if you think about my
electric field is varying
as a function of omega t.
So the instantaneously
my S, the energy flux--
right-- Poynting vector
gives me the energy flux.
I should not say the energy--
really should be power flux.
And what I have here is the--
it is a function of
2 omega, timewise.
Right?
Because if you look at
the E, it's I omega.
And if you have 2 sine omega
times each other, omega T
times each other,
you get 2 omega t.
So the energy--
the power flux here
is a rapid changing
function with time.
Because the frequency
of light, visible light
at least, is 10 to the 14 hertz.
So 2 omega will give you
even much faster, right?
So in this case,
normally we don't care.
We can't measure.
We cannot measure the
instantaneous power here.
And what we measure
is time average power.
So if you go to do
your time average--
time average-- and no
proof, but it's much easier
if you calculate this way.
It's the equivalent.
It's E cross H
complex conjugate.
And if you go to think about the
mass flux from the Schrodinger
equation, we wrote it as also
real part of a [INAUDIBLE]
and a grading of a
complex conjugate, right?
So you see the similarity
between these different flux.
I'm writing this as a E
cross H complex conjugate.
So all this, say, this is a
time average Poynting vector.
And now let's look at if I
have the plane wave propagating
inside a medium,
how it will change,
how the Poynting vector
change as a function of space.
So let's say I
have a plane wave,
and I'm careful
taking my coordinate.
This is z direction.
That's the direction
of propagation.
And this is the E direction.
It's in the x, so xy.
So y, then say, I would
expect my magnetic field will
be pointing E cross H,
gives me A, pointing out.
But you can prove it.
You can use your E. Let's say my
electric field in the Ex omega
t, so it's the x component--
electric field pointing
to x direction only.
And the magnitude of
the electrical field
times the exponential minus I.
And if you replace K relation
here, what we have,
K equals omega C0 N.
So I can take out the omega.
So omega t minus N C0 times z.
This is writing my plane wave
for electrical field polarized
in the x direction,
propagating in the z direction.
So from here, if I know
Ex, I can go back here
because I don't know H, right?
I say that H is a function, is
only in the Y direction only.
And in fact, you can use the
Maxwell equation to prove it.
So to find the H, I use
the first equation, right?
The curve for electrical field.
So I can say here, what I
have is a univector x, y, z
And have D Dx, D, Dy, and D, Dz.
So this is for
calculating the curve.
And I have Ex, so
x component only--
Ex 0 0.
That's the left-hand side
of the first equation.
And the Ex is a
function of z, remember.
Ex is just a vector direction.
It's not a function of
x It's a function of z,
if you look at here.
On the right-hand side,
I have B. B is mu, so D--
so mu DH Dt.
So I have DHx Dt.
And this is the x direction--
DHy Dt y direction,
DHz Dt z direction.
Right?
So I'm writing out the
first equation there--
vector.
OK.
And now if you
look at it, I said
this is a function
of z time z only.
So it's only a
function of z and time.
So if I take a derivative
of this, I-- of course,
the x component-- so
x, I take out this.
I have all 0.
Right?
So that means actually Hx is 0.
Hx is 0.
And then if I look at the
z component, here, here--
so Dz-- D0 Dx is 0.
DEx Dy-- but the Ex
is function of z only.
So that's also 0.
So I have Hz0.
So this will validate
what we're talking.
It's a transverse wave.
And H is perpendicular to E.
I only have the second
term, the y term--
DHy Dt, because
the y, if I say--
look at this, a vector.
So I take these two out.
So I have this 0--
D0 Dx.
And then I have DEx Dz.
This one is not 0.
Right?
So I have really minus
mu DHy Dt equals minus--
this is the second term on the
first row, so my sign is minus.
And then I have--
this is a positive,
this is negative--
is minus D Dx Dz.
Right?
So I know my Ex.
I have given my Ex DEx Dz.
I take out the derivative.
I integrate it with
respect to time.
I get my Hy.
Right?
So let me write down Hy.
In this case what do
you get, without going
through the intermediate steps--
my Hy component is E0 times
N mu C0 and exponential
minus I omega t
minus N C0 times z.
So again, it's a wave
propagating in the z direction.
And it's only y
direction component
is now 0, so it's perpendicular
to the electrical field.
And in fact, if you
look at E0 times this,
essentially is my Ex, right?
E0 times this exponential factor
is my Ex, not the vector, just
the form in the x direction.
So in fact, let me use
this right at the N--
mu 0 C0 times Ex.
But, say, this is
the magnitude of Ex
is not vector Ex
because the component is
in the y direction.
OK?
So that's Hy.
When I do my Poynting vector, I
will need all three components,
so that's why I'm writing out.
And in fact, what if you
have a positive sign--
rather than negative--
that's a forward propagating.
If you have a
backward propagating,
and your corresponding sign here
in the front will also change.
And you'll have, in
that case, you'll have
Hy equals negative N mu C0--
mu 0 C0 and Exy.
And this is for a negative
propagating wave, a sign
change.
And that's understandable
because what I have here,
this is the
propagation direction.
I said it's a right-hand wave.
So E cross H is pointing out.
But now if the wave goes
the other direction,
H will pointing in
the opposite direction
to form my right-hand wave.
And I commented, when
both E and, I say,
mu and epsilon are negative,
you have to do your left-hand.
And if you look
at this, here Hy--
if mu is negative, that changes
direction, real direction,
of the magnetic field.
And similarly, if
epsilon is negative,
that change the real direction.
So the negative root is actually
of this refractive index here,
is actually the requirement from
the Maxwell equation itself.
There's no-- it's just
a math requirement.
So it was the first pointed
out by this Russian scientist,
[INAUDIBLE],, if both the
epsilon and mu are negative,
you should take
the negative root.
But the nature of
materials all have, say,
epsilon mu pretty
close to vacuum.
So if the mu r is 1,
so normally people
say that's just an academic
exercise until, in the '90s,
people start to actually
make artificial structure
have a magnetic resonance.
So the magnetic response resists
the external magnetic field.
And that could
generate a negative mu.
And in this case, when
you can design material
with both epsilon and mu
negative together and become
negative.
So I am not done yet.
I have my Ex.
I have my Hy.
And I can go calculate
Poynting vector.
So let's calculate
the Poynting vector.
So this is the complexity
with the vector waves,
so you have to do always
a vector operation.
If you look at your Poynting
vector, and at the end,
you'll find out this
is only z component.
There's no x, y
component because your Ex
is in the x direction,
and the H is y direction.
And the cross product is
only in the z direction.
So let me skip that the
vector form and just say,
this is the time average
vector in the z direction--
is 1/2 real part of E, now
Ex Hy complex conjugate.
And this is what you get if
you write all these three
components, and you only have
the z direction component.
So now I can plug in Ex and Hy.
And you have to be careful
of this N refractive
index or optical constant, has
both real and imagined part.
So when I take a
complex conjugate,
this one I take complex.
This one I take complex.
This I I take inverse.
And this N, I have to
take complex conjugate.
So you have to do all that.
And you see, I omega
t minus I omega t,
because of plus I omega t.
So I omega t cancel.
E is negative I omega t because
that's last year-- because I,
actually, I was
doing time averages.
Time should not be there.
So this always cancels time.
And so what I have then
is a 1/2 real part of E0.
That's the electrical field.
And the exponential
negative negative
is a positive N. And C0
times z, that the first Ex--
Hy is E0 complex conjugate
N complex conjugate Dy
by mu 0 C0.
And I take mu is pretty
much as in vacuum.
And then I have an exponential,
and this becomes a plus I.
And this is a negative, so I
have exponential negative N
complex conjugate C0 z.
That my Poynting vector.
Right?
So what you have--
electric field,
complex conjugate--
that's just a magnitude.
These are real.
Now here I have to be careful.
It's the real part only.
Imaginary part drops out.
And these 2 exponential is
N minus N complex conjugate.
That gives me 2 I kappa.
2 I kappa-- oh, I forgot,
there is another I omega.
I omega should multiply in.
So I actually have I omega.
I have I omega, right?
So N complex only give
me 2 I kappa times
this another I,
actually is real.
So here N is real.
Here is the imaginary
part in the exponent.
So what I have then
is 1/2 E0 squared
and mu 0 C0 and
the real part, N,
and exponential minus
4 pi kappa over lambda.
And this lambda is
lambda in vacuum.
I have used, say,
omega C0, right?
Omega over C0 equals
2 pi over lambda.
So I substitute this in.
And that's how the Poynting
vector in a homogeneous media
of refractive index N kappa is
changing in the z direction.
Here is z.
It's exponential
decay function, right?
That decaying exponent, alpha,
is 4 pi kappa over lambda.
This is absorption coefficient.
And the inverse of this
absorption coefficient
is sometimes called
the skin depth.
So if the inverse--
that's a depth.
So you can see, when z equals
that skin depth inverse, delta
equals 1 over alpha.
When z equals delta,
we have the field
the decay to
exponential minus 1.
So what did we learn here?
You can say that when
electromagnetic field is
propagating in a lossy media,
kappa is now 0, the field decay
exponentially.
And that's the electromagnetic
wave is absorbed by the medium.
And in fact, this
is very important
when you make solar cells.
This determine how
deep the photon
penetrate into the material.
And silicon is an
indirect-gap semiconductor,
so the alpha is small
near the band gap.
So it's not a good absorber.
And because of that, you have
to use a pretty thick material
to absorb the photons.
And so that is a big problem
with the photovoltaics, silicon
photovoltaic, the material cost.
So any questions.
So this is propagating
in the same medium.
And the exponential law--
so sometimes we can write--
so this is the
Poynting vector, right?
And it's the, say,
the power flux.
And sometimes we
write intensity.
Intensity is the energy
per unit solid angle.
Intensity propagating
in a medium
is exponential
alpha times x, where
x is direction of propagation.
This is another way to
write the same form.
And this is also
called Beer's law.
It's a consequence of
the Maxwell equation,
but it's called the Beer's law.
So if you have a light
comes in onto a surface.
And what we wrote down here is
propagating inside the medium.
So we have not talked about
how much is reflected.
And what we talked
is, once you know
this field in this direction,
at this point, the flux,
and it will decay
exponentially inside.
So a material could be very
flattened, but very absorbing.
What does that mean?
It's conflicting, right?
So what does that mean is that
the reflectance is very large.
The reflectance,
R, is very large.
The material could
be 99% reflecting.
But once the electromagnetic
wave gets into the material,
the penetration
depth is very short.
It's absorbed.
Those that get into
the surface is absorbed
in very short distance.
In fact, all metals
behave that way.
Metal is very reflective,
but the field--
maybe 1% or 5% of this
wave gets into the metal,
absorbed typically
in 10 nanometers,
10 to 20 nanometers.
But if you have
indirect-gap semiconductor,
like silicon, this penetration
depth can be a millimeter.
If you do millimeter, you
want to capture that material.
So when you make a
solar cell, millimeter
mean a lot more materials,
so this is expensive.
So this is what's
inside propagation.
And now let's turn
our attention to what
happens at the interface, that
R. What's the reflectance?
What's the transmittance?
Reflection at one interface--
and this is very
similar to the scalar
wave from the
Schrodinger equation
we talked the last lecture.
And what we need is the field
on both sides of the interface
and use the continuity relation.
If you think about how we
did with the material wave ,
the wave function here.
You have the wave function
on the left equals right
at interface, and derivative
equal to each other.
So that's how we derive the
reflectance transmittance
for material waves.
And we do the same thing
for electromagnetic waves.
So what I have here is
flat interface 1 and 2.
And let me make my life slightly
easier by saying here is n1.
I can write a capital N1.
If I just write a small
N1, it means low loss.
If I write a capital
N1, means it has loss.
And here I can write a N2.
And I'll extend to the
case when there's loss--
discuss it.
The mass is identical, but there
are some subtle differences.
And I have the z direction.
This is my z direction
wave propagation.
And this is my x direction.
And I have a wave comes
in towards the interface.
This is my k direction.
That's the incident
wave direction.
And I have the
normal, the surface n.
So ki here is angle
of incidence, theta i.
And ki is the wave propagation
of the incident wave.
Two vector-- two
lines form a plane.
So this plane I call
is plane of incidence.
This is how I define
my reference plane.
So I have my plane of incidence.
And this is formed by n and
ki these are the two vector
for my plane of incidence.
Now I have to say the
field is a vector field.
It's perpendicular to ki.
But I have to define
which direction,
because it could be any of this
direction perpendicular to ki.
But I can-- any of this vector
I can decompose into two,
the sum of two vectors.
So I can always define,
if one case is my--
if I think this as my electric
field, is in the plane.
The other case is
perpendicular to the plane.
And once you know the solution,
is a linear combination
of the two.
So any other direction,
you decompose
the in-plane and cross-plane
perpendicular direction.
But then you have the choice
of, well, now depends on--
if this is my electrical
field, my magnetic field--
now, if you use the
right-hand rule,
what's the direction
of magnetic field?
AUDIENCE: It's going to be--
AUDIENCE: Coming up.
GANG CHEN: Coming up, right?
So E incident-- and
that's a vector.
And the magnetic
field is pointing up.
OK.
So there are three
names for this--
depends on which one you--
we need to remember.
It turns out for over this many
years, I always get confused.
I always say, OK, I like to
remember this as a TM wave.
TM means Transverse Magnetic.
So this case, what
I draw is TM wave.
That's the magnetic field is
perpendicular to the plane
of incidence.
So three names--
the other two names
is relative to the
electrical field, then.
It's parallel to the
plane of the incidence.
So here you either
call it the TM wave,
or you call it the parallel--
P wave-- or you use
the symbol of parallel.
So it's three
different notations.
What I have here is
for the electric field.
And here is-- when
I say transverse, is
whatever what's follow.
Transverse is a TM.
That means magnetic
field is perpendicular.
TE mean the electrical
So what I'm going to
derive is the situation
where the magnetic field is
perpendicular to the plane
of the incidence.
And now I need to write--
when the wave comes in,
I could have reflection.
I have transmission.
So here reflection,
the wave vector,
and transmission,
the wave vector.
And in each medium I
have a plane waveform,
I know the plane waveform.
This is my plane waveform.
I do not know the amplitude.
And my wave vector,
I need to relate
to what direction the wave
is going for the reflected
and transmitted.
So here is my theta
R, if I use moment n,
angle theta t to denote it.
So I can write--
because if I want to
write this k by the R--
R is any point in the plane xyz.
And k, I have to write it now
in terms of the notation I have.
This k, I have to
say kx, ky, kz.
And I write my k--
univector, not a magnitude.
This is the total.
The total, of course,
is related to omega C.
But what's the univector is
related to direction only.
So the univector, I can write
it as this is the vector
direction, so what's my--
under my, say, z is k
times the cosine theta.
Right?
X is sine theta.
So I have really my sine
theta i zero cosine theta i.
And this is my
incident univector.
And my univector of reflection
is here, R. So x direction
is still sine theta R0.
But the z direction
is negative now.
This is my
propagation direction.
My z direction is negative--
so negative cosine theta R.
And my t direction--
oh, this is a univector is
sine theta t 0 cosine theta t.
Now we encourage
you to-- everybody
really get comfortable.
It took me many, many
years to get comfortable.
But at least you should
do your exercise.
And let's say I'm
giving you TM wave.
You can go back and
do TE wave and go
through the derivation
of what's reflectance,
what's transmittance when
we go through an interface.
And I made a comment
in the last lecture.
When people do electrical-- say
this material wave Maxwell--
no, Schrodinger equation, we
did a lot more incidence, right?
And here can see, I'm doing
general any angle of incidence.
So you should go back
and redo that problem,
any angle of incidence.
You'll be able to do it.
So now, what I do next is to
write a component because I
need the boundary conditions.
Recall, for the material
wave, Schrodinger equation
is the wave function
is continuous.
Derivative wave
function is continuous.
And what's my corresponding
boundary condition
for Maxwell equation?
And it turns out
that any interface--
and this is actually
very general.
How you derive an
interface condition?
When you do heat
transfer, you do the same.
You apply-- so when
you do a heat transfer,
you apply your boundary
condition to-- you
apply your equation
of energy balance
to both sides of the interface.
So if I have-- this is a--
let's say, many of you probably
more familiar with the heat
transfer, so I'll try to
write down the boundary
condition for this.
If this is a liquid,
this is solid, right?
Apply the energy conservation.
I see on the solid side,
the heat conduction
coming towards this interface
equals the convection going
through the other interface.
I'm applying the first law.
The thickness is 0.
There is heat
comes in from here,
but my limit is thickness
0, so that term drops out.
When you apply first rule,
you have four surfaces
in my drawing here.
So I do the same thing
when I do Maxwell equation.
Or you do Schrodinger
equation-- how you derive--
you apply, in the case
of Schrodinger equation,
you have your
material wave that's
saying the matter
must be continuous.
With that you can write the
equation we gave before.
And here, I have to apply--
take that control volume,
apply all those four equations,
integrate it over
that control volume
and take the limit that
the thickness approaches 0.
And with that you can write down
all your boundary conditions.
And the boundary
condition is the n,
the univector of the norm, and
D2 minus D1 equals rho surface.
This is the real charge
accumulating on the surface.
If you have a current flowing
uniformly through the material,
everywhere you have
a current density.
In that case, what's your
surface charge density?
0 because everywhere is uniform.
When you get your
thickness go to 0, that's
the total number of
charge in this one,
even a small thickness is 0.
So normally this is 0.
But if you do--
let's say some of your may
work with electrochemistry.
And in this case, you
have absorb the charge
on the surface.
And in that case, your
surface charge is not 0.
So you can say what
is the n dot product.
That means is the vertical
component, the component
perpendicular to the interface.
Because this is n direction.
This is parallel to n direction.
So basically, the displacement
field, the difference
is the surface charge because
each surface charge add
a coulomb field on top of it.
The addition gives
you the difference
in the displacement field.
And then you have
the tangential then
is a cross product
to the interface.
So this is a parallel
component, is 0.
So the electric
field is parallel
to the interface and continuous.
And then you do your magnetic.
First is the dot
product, is zero.
And the tangential component
is the surface charge--
surface current.
Again, the surface
current is something
that you need to be careful.
Really depends on, for example--
I give you a case.
If I have a graphene sheet,
I try to make a solar cell.
And graphene sheet
is my electrode.
And when I try to apply
the boundary condition,
I will see that, in that case,
because of the graphene sheet
has a much higher current
density than the rest
of the region, I will take that
as my surface current density.
But most of the time, if
this is homogeneous material
and you take your infinite
thickness, this drops out.
So what it also means
is the magnetic field,
tangential component
is usually continuous.
So basically, electrical field
is continuous because D--
no, this D has to
be epsilon 2 D2--
E2 epsilon 1 E1.
But tangential component is
continuous electrical field.
And magnetic field, the
perpendicular component
is continuous, and the
tangential component
is the difference of
the electrical current,
surface current.
The other with the
singular surface
current is, you know that on
a wire through a conductor
current, you've got a magnetic
field that's surrounding.
Right?
So when I have a surface
current flowing here,
I have a magnetic field going
in the tangential direction.
That's why you have
this relationship.
But that's all derived from
applying the Maxwell equation
to the interface.
So those are the
general conditions.
And now I'm going to
apply those conditions.
I need to write down.
I do a little bit dirty work--
write down all those
components, tangential
and perpendicular components,
and apply the boundary
conditions.
Need to write electrical
field, magnetic field.
So-- but you need
to develop a habit.
Yeah, it's all plane wave.
That's what I wrote down before.
And for the TM wave, where
the electric field is what I--
incident, right?
So it's an incident.
I have three waves.
One is the incident,
the other is reflective,
the other is transmitted.
I have to write down
all of them to count.
So this is the incident,
and it's a vector
because it's not parallel to x
or parallel to any direction.
It has an angle.
And then exponential, I need
to carry my phase factor,
minus i omega t minus--
you go to look at what
we have here-- k dot r.
k I already pull out, so omega
C0 times N. And now I have ki
is sine theta i cosine theta i0.
And r is xyz.
So the top product of these
two gives me N1x Xi sine theta
i plus N1z cosine theta i.
So this is where we
should be careful--
and C0.
That's the incident.
And it's really tedious,
but once you get used to it,
this is just a phase factor.
And remember, this one
actually has a component
because the vector Ei has
a component in x direction,
and it has component
in the z direction.
So this, you can say, is
Ex and 0Ez, the incident.
And you can do your
vector decomposition
to write down this component.
So you similarly write once
they reflected and exponent.
And then very soon,
all these exponents
are going to drop off.
So I just want to write
it to show you how
we got this, why it drops out.
Minus n1 because-- z
cosine theta r over C0.
Recall, right, because this
is kr, it has a negative,
so I have positive
becomes a negative.
Theta i becomes theta r.
And the average
is still medium 1.
And transmitted, let
me see-- parallel--
parallel.
And exponential minus i
omega t minus n2x sine theta
t plus n2--
I can just look at that--
times z cosine.
See that here I'm just
changing my symbol.
And changing medium, from
medium 1 to medium 2.
So it looks very long.
It's just the phase factor.
I'm writing out the details.
And this is the
amplitude and vector
of the transmitted reflected,
which we want to find out.
And in fact, we also
want to find out
what are the directions,
see the reflected direction
and transmitted direction.
We're not assuming
anything a priori.
So we have the electrical field.
We also want write
the magnetic field.
And if you check the load for
any plane wave, if I can write,
that's how, in the homogeneous
medium, we derived, right?
Given the electric field, I
can derive with magnetic field.
You go to the
first equation, you
write the other magnetic
field component.
And then now, in this case,
magnetic field is a TM wave.
It's only in the y direction.
Right?
So let me give you--
this is a E, right?
And H is in the y direction.
Remember it's Hy
only because that's
the part of the mass
you substituted in
and also part of
the physics when we
say we're considering TM wave.
So this is only y direction.
And you can say that, it's
related to electric field
after use the first equation.
So n1 mu zero C0, and is a
parallel of the electric field.
So it's related to magnitude
of the electric field incident.
This is the incident
magnetic field.
And backwards-- reflected
is going backward.
So there is a negative sign.
The other way to think
about negative sign
is, if this is the
electric field,
and this is the same--
in the same direction,
you can see here, E cross H. The
H must be going into the board.
So I have a negative sign.
That's a [INAUDIBLE].
It's when you substitute it into
the equation, you'll get this.
So mu zero C0 and
exponential t--
let me write this phase
factor is the same.
Phase factor is the
same as reflected,
and n2 mu 0 C0 and parallel--
oh, this is r, reflected.
This is a transmitted--
exponential phase
factor of transmitting.
So here, what [INAUDIBLE]
in this one is phi incident,
and this is the phi reflected.
And what's inside here
is my phi transmitted.
So what really is
tedious is carrying out
this phase factor, which
will drop out very quickly.
Now I'm going to
apply the continuity
The electric field
tangential component,
because I don't have
any surface charge--
tangential component, electric
field, and magnetic field
are all continuous.
And you see, you could
apply the perpendicular
field is continuous.
And either way, you'll
get the same result.
So let me apply this relation.
What I have here is the
tangential component, so
electric field.
And my electric field is in
the tangential component,
is Ex, continuous
in the x direction.
If you look at it,
my electric field
in the x direction for
incident, for reflected--
I have to project it
into all x direction.
And that's so the field--
you need to sum up each side.
It's a total field.
It's not just one.
I didn't say incident
or reflected.
It's the total
field on each side.
Same when we do
the wave function.
It's the total wave function
due to incident and reflection.
So this field summation is
very different than when
you do this--
typically, if you've
taken radiation,
it's doing intensity add up.
Now I'm doing in
the field add up.
And that equals the other side.
So if I do this, what
I have here is Eix,
so incident x component.
And exponential, I need to
carry this phase factor.
Z is 0.
I was clever choosing
my coordinate.
Z is 0 at the interface.
So all z's drop out.
Right?
And omega t, i omega
t, you look at it.
Every term has a
negative i omega t.
That will drop off.
Right?
So I'm not going to carry
[INAUDIBLE] i omega t.
I'm not writing down z.
Z equal 0.
And I'm only x.
So I'm going to write
this x component term--
is i omega n1x and
sine theta i over C0.
That's the incident
component in the x direction.
And the reflected component in
the x direction, exponential i
omega.
n1x sine theta r
equals- over C0--
equals transmitted in the x
direction exponential i omega.
n2x sine theta i over C0.
So this is the continuity
in the electrical field
in the x direction.
I can ride the magnetic
field similarly.
But I want to do one argument
so that I can drop out
all those exponents.
You can look at this.
This equation has to
be valid for x point,
every point x in the plane.
For that to happen,
your only way
is all that exponential
equal to each other.
Otherwise, you
have zero solution.
Right?
Because I only have one
transmitted one reflected.
So x-- for this equation to
have a long term solution,
all exponential terms
equal to each other.
And when I have this omega,
of course, doesn't change.
And so you can see,
the n1 sine theta i,
from here equal n1 sine theta
r equals n2 sine theta t.
If that happens, it gives me
all the exponent are equal.
So this is what you learned
in high school, right?
Optics-- the incident angle
equals reflected angle--
Snell Law, right?
This solution is theta
i equals theta r.
And n1 sine theta i
equals n2 sine theta t.
That's a refractional.
Right?
So this gives me theta
i equals theta r.
And n1 sine theta i
equals n2 sine theta t.
So this is a Snell law.
And another way to
think about this
is, if you look back into
our general solution,
this exponent is kx--
kx times x.
So what I have here,
is a kx times x.
So kx is the continuous.
So kx must be, say, i
incident equals kx reflected
equals kx transmitted.
And this is an often called the
lateral momentum conservation.
The momentum component
in the direction parallel
to the interface are
conserved for incident,
reflected, and transmitted.
So it turns out, depends
on who you're talking to,
people use a completely
different term.
Of course, for a specular
smooth surface-- here
we say very smooth.
We don't have many--
any assumption of
surface roughness.
In this case, I have an incident
equal reflection and Snell
law valid.
And then, say--
I think you heard me talk about
the gratings, Bragg reflection,
right?
If I have periodic
structure on the surface,
and it turns out this is
momentum conservation--
this momentum is like crystal
momentum is not exactly--
you have to always obey it.
So the structure, when it has
a component in the x direction,
in this case if it's a periodic
structure in the x direction,
it gives you the structure,
the geometrical component
of wave vector in
this direction.
That's the Bragg condition.
So when you have a light comes
in, say periodic structure,
you have reflection
only in certain spots.
In this case is the
crystal providing
your lateral momentum.
So this momentum
conservation rule here,
lateral momentum conservation,
if you have roughness,
actually your light
can go many directions.
So if you complete
a rough random,
your reflection actually can
go, in the case of periodic,
it goes certain spots.
And if it's rough, it
goes all directions.
So it's here is a roughened
surface that provides you
this geometrical momentum
needed to obey the momentum
conservation rule.
So like I said, depends
on who you talk to.
And then when I deal with
the lateral magnetic wave,
people normally say
this is a rough surface
and diffused reflection.
You talk to electrical
engineer, you
check the electrical
literature, they
don't talk about rough surface.
They always say, OK, it's a
momentum conservative, long
conserve.
It's talking about same thing.
So now with that, I drop
off all the exponents.
You can see here, this
equals this, equals this.
So I have written a lot
of complex expressions.
Now I'm going to simplify this.
Let me write here.
And I'm going to simplify to
have Eix plus Eir equals Etx.
That's my-- this gives--
the Snell law gives me the x
component of the electric field
is continuous--
the magnitude now.
The phase factor already taken
care of by the Snell law.
And of course, the Eix
is the Ei cosine theta i.
And this is a
parallel component.
This is where I keep
talking about the TM wave--
plus E parallel r reflected
cosine theta r equals
E transmitted cosine theta t.
So this is written in terms of
the amplitude of the incident,
reflected, transmitted field.
Now I have my next relation.
This is the magnetic field.
This is continuous.
Magnetic field is the y
direction and doesn't have--
because it's only y direction.
You see, this is
all y component.
So on the first media, I
have the sum of these two.
The phase factor is the same--
Snell law-- equals
the second medium.
So what I have here is n1.
And in fact, the
mu C cancel, right?
Mu C is the same.
So n1 E parallel i minus
here the reflected--
is n1 E parallel r equals
n2 on the other side--
E parallel t.
So those are the two
equations I went through to--
I'm looking for.
I'm looking for how
much is reflected
versus the incident,
how much is transmitted
field versus the incident.
And I have enough
equation to do that.
So now you go to
solve for this ratio.
And I have my
reflection coefficient
is E parallel r E parallel
i equals n1 cosine thetas
t minus n2 cosine theta
i And n1 cosine theta
t plus n2 cosine theta i.
So this is the
reflection coefficient.
And transmission coefficient
is a 2n1 cosine theta
i and n1 cosine theta i--
no, theta t plus
n2 cosine theta i--
same denominator.
So those are the reflection
and transmission coefficient.
It's not a reflectance
or transmittance yet.
AUDIENCE: In the first
term on the far right,
n2 cosine theta
i, is that right?
So you're--
GANG CHEN: Right.
And so you cross this.
AUDIENCE: It's not n1?
GANG CHEN: This is a n1 cosine
theta t, n2 cosine theta i.
OK?
They switch.
AUDIENCE: N2 cosine theta i.
GANG CHEN: Right.
Yeah.
It's different expression
if you look at the t.
So if you look at--
if it's tE
polarization, you'll get
a slight different expression.
But it's a similar.
So I would not remember this.
Every time I have to check.
But what we have
now is the magnitude
of reflected and
transmitted fields.
And based on this,
I can go further,
calculate the Poynting vector.
I will calculate
my Poynting vector
because I want to
find the energy.
So your Poynting vector--
and you can say,
for this case, you
have a component
in the x direction.
You have component
in the z direction.
And what you really care when
you go through a interface,
at least if you
look at transport
in the interface
direction is what's
the component in
the z direction.
That's the energy flux
going across the interface.
So if you check your
Poynting vector,
and we will define
reflectance, R
equals parallel
in the z direction
reflected incident
in the z direction.
And you see, it's just the
reflection coefficient squared.
And that's because, if you go
to check your load, Poynting
vector S, in the
homogeneous media,
you would say there is something
like a complex reflective
index.
But because it's in the
same media, that cancels.
So that's just a few pages
ago we talked about it
at the beginning, right?
And the transmittance--
in fact, maybe I
should have used transmisivity
for a flat surface.
As I said, if you
do reverse, it's
an intrinsic material property.
But if you have rough, we do
reflectance transmittance.
If it's a intrinsic, it's
reflectivity transmisivity.
And here is the idea.
And so that's if you have ideal
surface, you always have this.
So transmittance,
tau-- it doesn't
matter whether it's a parallel
or perpendicular wave.
But here, what I have
is for transmittance
I have to be careful because
the Poynting vector is going
from one side to the other.
So I have N2 cosine theta
t and the real part of N1.
So this is when the theta i--
this is when both sides have a,
say, complex reflective index.
This here is where it's a
little bit more complex.
So here is called a
Fresnel Coefficient--
French.
So Fresnel Coefficients,
for reflection transmission
at the interface, here is
for parallel polarized.
So that's the electric field.
That is in the
plane of incidence.
And let me put a parallel here.
And if it's a electric
field in the perpendicular
plane of incidence, you go
through the same derivation.
And there are different set
of Fresnel Coefficients.
And here it gives you the
reflectance and transmittance
based on those coefficients.
So let me make a
few more comments.
Here are we see this is a--
we discussed the name here.
This is a TM.
The other name is--
so here is a TM wave.
If the electrical field is
perpendicular to the plane
the incidence, it's
called a T wave.
And this is a S and
perpendicular sign.
So it depends on
which book you read,
you use it's own notation.
And in fact, there is
even more confusion
if you read a different book.
And sometimes the people are
write N equals n minus i kappa.
I wrote a n plus i kappa.
And that depends on whether, in
this waveform factor plane wave
expression, whether you put
a negative sign in the front.
If you don't use
this selective sign,
you should have a
n minus i kappa.
So I like to put
the negative sign
so that it's a n plus i kappa.
Different books use
different notation.
And there is no consistency.
I can't solve that problem.
The other is let's look
at this expression.
And in fact, you read
a [INAUDIBLE] paper,
if you have are
doing your homework.
He used exactly what we
have here, Snell law,
for surface wave, for when
the epsilon mu is negative.
And sometimes this
goes to infinite.
This r itself goes to infinite.
What that mean the
r goes to infinite?
It just means that there's no
wave can come in and couple
to the surface.
So in that case, what it
has is a surface wave.
And the wave decays
exponentially
from both sides of the surface.
So what it have is a wave
that decays exponentially
from the surface, both sides.
And this is where he was
discussing different solutions
of the Maxwell equation.
So hopefully you
see that it's not
too far from what we discussed.
You just need to recognize this.
And also, when theta i is 0--
that's a normal incident.
When theta i is 0, cosine
theta t, all this are 0,
so what I have here is r
equals n1 minus n2 n1 plus n2.
So if you go to check
for the material
wave we derived at
the last lecture,
it's k1 minus k2, k1 plus k2.
It's the same expression.
And in fact, you
can write into k--
[INAUDIBLE] use k completely--
[INAUDIBLE] paper.
You go to read, he used k.
He didn't use n, so that
he can have epsilon.
He did not use n
because, whether you
take a positive root,
a negative root--
that's for the debate there.
But in this case, R is--
the reflectance R--
is the R squared,
so giving you an
order of magnitude.
So you can see
it's very similar.
The wave expressing
all very similar--
reflectance, transmittance.
But let's say glass.
Glass n is about 1.5.
How much reflection is
interface of glass has.
Air is 1, so 1.5 minus
1.5, divide by 2.5.
That's one phase.
Square-- 1/25 1/25 is what?
4%?
Right?
So typically, one glass
interface give you 4%,
and a glass has to interface.
So that's 0.96 line times 0.96.
So glass transmittance
is about 92%, 93%.
It looks like fine, unless you
really care about efficiency.
And 92%, if you put a
[INAUDIBLE] glass there--
layer there-- in
solar cells, and then
gaps, and you'll get
a, say, below the 90%.
You'll get the loss
of 10% of your energy.
That's a lot.
Sometimes it looks small.
Secondly, if you
look at the silicon--
so it's good to
remember these numbers.
Silicon-- anything about 3.5.
So 3.5 minus 1-- so
silicon interface,
how much reflection is?
2.5 divided by 4.5 square.
Right?
2.5 divided by 4.5,
that's about 50%.
50% square, 25%, right?
So the glass of interface
reflection is about 25%, 30%.
If you heat silicon--
if all the light is absorbed--
of course, in between the
gap, you don't get absorbed--
then the emittance
of silicon then
is about 0.7 because
the reflection is 30%,
and the rest of
it gets absorbed.
Absorption equals reflection--
absorption equals emission.
That's Kerchhoff's law.
So this gives you now
the value that you will
see that you can appreciate.
OK?
We'll continue next lecture.